Once we've got our histogram,
there are a lot of statistics we
can run on it to characterize it.
For instance, of course we might
be interested in the mean.
We might also be interested
in the standard deviation.
Which is essentially on average how far
do individual measurements
deviate from the mean.
Another very important measure
is something called Kurtosis.
Kurtosis comes from a Greek word
that means curved or arching.
So what does Kurtosis mean?
Well let me show you.
Kurtosis tells us about
the tails of the distribution.
So the tails are the parts
out here towards the ends.
And if we assume that our
distribution is similar to
a Gaussian distribution,
or normal distribution.
The measure of kurtosis
tells us how much
different our histogram isfrom that
traditional Gaussian distribution.
So in this case we have
what are called fat tails.
We got them over here and over here.
What that means is that
there are occasional,
and more frequent than would happen if
we had a regular Gaussian distribution.
There are frequently large
excursions more frequently than if
this was a normal distribution.
If you were to measure
the kurtosis of this histogram,
you would get a positive number.
Meaning that there are more
occurrences out in these tails.
Than would be expected if it
were a normal distribution.
If you measured a negative kurtosis.
It would mean that there are many fewer
occurrences out here on the tails.
Than would be expected if it
were a normal distribution.
So we can plot our data in this sort
of bar chart called a histogram.
We can measure statistics on it like
standard deviation, mean and kurtosis.
And remember the following
about kurtosis.
If we’ve got a positive kurtosis,
that means we’ve got fat tails,
like in this example.
There’s more occurrences
outside in the tails
than would normally happen
with a Gaussian distribution.
And if we’ve got a negative kurtosis,
we’ve got skinny tails,
meaning there’s less out there.
Now, I’m going to hand it over to Dave,
and she’s going to show you
how to make this plot and
calculate these numbers in Python.